it's hardly a reassuring sound but it is
designed to get our attention a 10
second alert that will be sent to every
mobile phone across the country in a
life-threatening emergency that the
government is trialing there will be
many people that see this as part of a
slightly alarmist process of of us
worrying about a coming War perhaps I
think that's a red herring actually
other things like flooding events
theoretically in certain places at
certain times this this could be useful
could save lives particularly if things
get this bad its primary use will be for
serious weather-related incidents it
does flood here quite a lot and things
so um yeah it'd be quite a good idea I
can see the benefits of it definitely in
terms of
like making everybody aware of the same
thing at the same time
this technology is so specific it has
the ability to Target local people the
river behind me is prone to flooding if
it did local people could be notified
and told perhaps to evacuate their homes
but this system also has the ability to
inform us of national incidents too
security whether or otherwise it could
for instance have been used last summer
when some 20 homes were destroyed in
wildfires that ripped through the
village of Weddington in East London
the system is already used
internationally but only when there's an
immediate risk to life
I think this just helps us to be better
prepared to deal with those
circumstances and in those circumstances
it could be the sound that saves your
life the domestic abuse Charities warned
for some it could do the opposite I'm
not sure that it's been fully
appreciated just quite how dangerous the
discovery of a hidden phone can be for
women and we need to do absolutely
everything we can to make sure that
everyone is aware that this is happening
and how to turn it off
the notification can be turned off on
all devices and it doesn't tap into Data
the government says the alert on the
23rd of April is just a test if heard
after then it shouldn't be ignored
ashnaharinag Sky News